Our Economy – Ō Tātou Ōhanga
Our District is home to more than 6,300 businesses
and a highly skilled labour force
however, over 40% of our working population are currently
employed outside of the District.
Around three quarters of those would prefer to work locally if suitable work was available.
Of the 460 hectares of land currently zoned
for business, around a hundred of that is
underutilised or vacant.
Are we providing the right opportunities for
businesses in the right locations?
We need to consider what type of environments
large employers are looking for, while also
making Waimakariri a place where talented people want to live
Our District – Our Future, Waimakariri 2048
aims to:
So what do you think?
Let us know your thoughts and find out more
about the District Development Strategy at
waimakariri.govt.nz